[Music]
three two one boom here we go what's up
everyone welcome to simulation we are
now sitting down with dr. jr. thanks for
having me on thanks for come on the show
it's all a spontaneous I love it I love
it when you message me and I'm like you
haven't seen the studio yet let's do is
is great I love the light I love what
you and Ron have set up here this is
very comfy I'm glad you like it
it's step one step one you know you got
a hundred you're episode 101 which is
awesome amazed by the throughput and I'm
sure you're learning things constantly
as is your audience so I can't wait to
see what happens next
yeah let's see if we can get more
creators more build a creative warehouse
where so many other people can leverage
these tools especially young people and
underprivileged areas that have all
these great ideas and and also let's
build out this educational content today
we have a good amount of diverse
information we're gonna be talking about
for those that don't know we put it in
the bio June is the president of Paul to
investors he's also the sponsor of the
Paul to longevity prize and plenty of
more information about June can be found
at in the Lincoln bio dr. joon-young
calm so let's start with the National
Institute of nutrition need oh yeah so
we're exploring the concept of a way to
increase funding for food scientists and
specifically federal funding we hosted a
gathering last year of food scientists
and what was a parent was the fact that
there really is no consensus in food
science across so many topics so even
things that you might believe to be true
there's always that there's nothing
opinions somewhere that hasn't been
heard and that it's been this way
forever so
the standard understanding science was
you got to eat more carbs that was
nineteen seven seven days and now it's
low carbs one day eggs are good when the
eggs are bad right cholesterol is I mean
so I think there's so much contradictory
information that has left the public
confused so when you unpack all that it
looks like there is just fundamentally
not enough funding to do the rigorous
science and that that's necessary to
establish evidence-based nutrition
there's a lot of lobbyists dollars in
there moving things in the directions
they want well there's some industrial
funding and I think the person who could
say is thank you because at least
they're funding food science you know
really it's only in the recent past that
we've awoken to the the importance of
what we eat in terms of health that's a
relatively new understanding and the
grand arc of health science so when you
look at the existing institutions
there's really no institutional
organization that's accountable for
nutrition for public benefit yeah let's
see the ESD is accountable for ESD a
USDA United States Department of
Agriculture it was a putting law by
Lincoln in 1862 so it's the poorest
growers it's also 150 years ago the USDA
yes formed yes Wow yes and how well done
that's that's it yeah but it was not to
call the people's Department and because
we forget that we were agrarian that
long ago and the reason was the people's
Department because because we're
agrarian that Department was really
about the people now the USDA is mostly
about the growers but growers only 2% of
the population so food was something
that you got from your parents there's
no principal agency problem principal
agent problem and now we have a
counterparty risk because somebody else
is growing your food and it's happening
it's happened really slowly just like
boiling the Frog we haven't noticed that
the what's really changed about food is
who gives it to you that's the central
change and everything else is an
Epiphone I went on from that change so
the USDA is still beholding to the
interest of the growers but it's also in
charge of nutrition so it's you know
it's got this dual mission and given the
evolution of however things go
maybe it makes sense to put nutrition
under Department Health and Human
Services under HSS you got not only
there are they in charge of health but
they're charge of food through the FDA
food labeling a little bit through CDC
liberal for NIH each HS human health
services think about the country as a
set of departments and then beneath the
actually FDA is beneath HHS yes so is
the Department of Agriculture and
nutrients I think is actually a separate
Department is separate than human health
service yeah okay think about
departments like Department Interior
Department Health and Human Services
Department of Homeland Security yep yep
and underneath those essentially they
get the budget appropriations from
Congress and then there are sub
institutions are underneath that so NIH
is under HHS as is Medicare holy cow oh
yeah so trillion dollars the department
they go bundle all that in so that's the
reporting structure so HHS is
accountable to our to public health and
so they're doing the funding to provide
not only health for the country through
insurance Medicaid Medicare but also
science that supports the well-being of
the public and it's an incredible
department yep with a long history they
do a lot of things well in fact it's
done so well that it's created these new
challenges for us which is dealing with
aging dealing with abundance and the
obesity dealing with disease are food
related food and so tired related
chronic conditions you know they're come
for about a trillion dollars of spending
the chronic conditions themselves it's
diet as a component to that so diabetes
diabetes obesity exactly hypertension
Ottoman diseases food diet has some
effect on a lot of these things so
that's a growth market its massive it's
something that we need to deal with is a
huge tax on society yeah
so given the scale of the the toll of
cost and that food plays in health
the amount of public dollars we spend on
food research is very smaller so if you
pull together all the different agencies
spending there was a jamup article last
year all the public funds at the federal
level combined it is about 1.5 billion
there's some money come from state as
well that's a really small number of 1.5
billion for nutritional science from
federal sources NIH is 30 billion we
spend 30 billion on candy per year
Valentine's Day and Halloween and so
given the fact that you know diet is now
being recognized as a source of both
health and disease and maybe even as
therapeutics for the 21st century should
we set up something that'll allow us to
build up the scientific knowledge that
the food can better serve public oh
that's the that's the basic concept
we're exploring the concept convenience
stakeholders and you know we're gonna
advocate for increasing funding and
possibly advocate for increasing funding
through federal government and possibly
through you know this we're not lob
we're not the ones lobbying lobbyists
well you know they do their own thing
but just advocating for a greater
awareness of the potential to create
something like an ni n to support food
scientist and so ok let's see let's do a
quick unpack of what your roadmap is
with NI n so it's the pairing together
both a government with with some private
and some lobby and some science into a
package that is trying to uncover
objective truths about nutrition and
then the way that that impacts
healthcare and that hopefully that we
can teach our kids down the line to make
some sort of truth in the area of
nutrition well broadly but it'd be great
Drive more funding into rigorous science
and nutrition so evidence-based
nutrition and some in the federal
government can have some role now the
federal government is gonna make their
own set of decisions the idea of
creating new Institute I mean it has
go be done by Congress we can advocate
for it we can give Congress you know
input in terms of and when we say we I'm
talking about the food scientists
themselves as a community as a public
the stakeholders can share information
or perspectives so that it puts Congress
into power because they're ultimately
they're charged with the authority to
serve the public interest and if they
think that makes sense you know it takes
forever to get these things done the
National Cancer Institute
it took three decades for that to be put
in the law the National Cancer Act of
1937 I hope this doesn't take us long
but we have a starting point I mean
there's a lot of people you know that
are now talking about it the
stakeholders and and hopefully the
community will come up with something
and hopefully the federal government and
the lawmakers will see some merit in
this that this is a big need and how
however gets it gets instantiate I'm
sure it'll evolve from here but at least
we have a starting point we held our
first launch meeting last week of
convening of stakeholders is it seems
like bringing together stakeholders is
crucial across all different types of
industries that is going on there's not
enough convening of stakeholders in
conversations about health about
nutrition about education about the
state of the economy about all these
different ways to convene stakeholders
to discuss exactly how to best move
forward would and this is these are
these are the reasons why I really
appreciate having you in my life because
you're constantly dropping all this all
this important all these important
cultural transformations on to me and I
really appreciate them is now a good
time talk about high peace and how it
relates to an intership sure so it's not
relating then but it's fascinating okay
culture if they're somebody's watching
and they're under 18 they've been all
about this
I'm as fascinated by the the border that
exists culturally between
you know my friends in my community and
this high peace community which is
there's millions of people involved and
yet most people I know have never even
heard the word and I think the word is
almost 10 years old it was it was coined
by somebody who was kind of a fashion
commentator um but in a nutshell the
hypest culture and the high peace
arbitrage that's going on is this idea
just what do you think every business
model has been done and tried of course
people always come with new ones in a
market like apparel where technically
there is infinite inventory people are
doing these brands are doing these very
limited edition releases and and they're
creating us and they actually have
co-created a secondary market that
allows a quick arbitrage yeah of the
initial consumers in a secondary market
only 20 of these shoes or jackets are
gonna be released then there's a big
line out the door people trying to
negotiate and bit each other at the door
get the product immediately flip it on
eBay or exactly the fact that there is
like a StubHub for these things allows
young people who are there long on time
short on finances yeah to actually be
entrepreneurs so they can insert it by
having instant liquidity they can go to
their parents you know they may be 15
years old living in inner city and say
hey mom can I borrow $300 and somebody
need a fourth like whoa I'm gonna buy
shoes and like are you crazy the mom I'm
gonna bring home a thousand profit yeah
first time that happens you've got a
customer right yeah because I'm really
the geniuses they have done as much work
an architect in the secondary market to
ensure the quiddity is just like
anything else the liquidity is so
valuable which by the way the Bachchan
community's gonna have to figure out the
quiddity because they're solving for a
lot of other problems at once so without
the liquidity you know you run into
other types of issues so by providing
liquidity to the first buyers you have
everything else the hype that comes with
the release
which creates a brand equity the massive
margins and you have to bake it do very
little promotion of marketing it's all
done to the community and it's totally
under the radar the parents like this
about what you just described so
interesting because like you said there
are heavy on time low on finances versus
heavy on money low on time yeah and it's
so fascinating that they can both
exchange just like that and help each
other there in that sense this was
recently happening with Hamilton in San
Francisco we had friends that were like
oh I'm just going wait in line I'm like
okay and they're like I'm just going to
buy tickets and sell them immediately
afterward that's this market exists for
apparel for tickets to events where else
does it appear I mean so some people
call that scalping you know and right
now the drops are happening outside of
apparel shoes are big market but you
know their sleds and lots of random
things it could but it really is a
cultural phenomenon as much as an
economic phenomenon so the economics of
these are fascinating there are so many
mathematicians now involved who they
literally these brands have you know
PhDs figuring out the right numbers like
price here unit number of outlets and
here the returns here the secondary
market so it was a very scientific field
Wow
and it allows you to just sort through
psychology and economic terms and
mathematical terms and model it out I
don't know what kind of runways couldn't
have but it's already been around for
many years the last three years have
been intense it hasn't quite jump the
shark yet because most people means your
culture so have never even heard the
word but they've seen the lines yeah you
go to like the Supreme store in New York
City it's like a four line to get in
yeah and you're like what are they doing
they're like you're buying clothes
limited releases on brands this is like
you like you just described all of the
complicated math and economic theory
that's going into how much of this good
should we produce and then how much will
that good be sold for how much will it
be sold for in a secondary market and
you describe that side of things and
then there's also the side of things
that you began describing that I think
so crucial is
the kid in an underprivileged area that
has a ton of time going up to his mom
and saying let me borrow 300 bucks so I
can go wait in the line for two days and
bring back a thousand dollars with just
time that's all they need it's just time
and that upfront 300 so I think that's a
very interesting way to also uplift
underprivileged areas if it's possible
to go and communicate hypebeast culture
to underprivileged and underdeveloped
all that what they start there all over
bin' la that's what the whole field hold
the movement started and now it's
becoming cooler so other kids are
getting in and it's getting now even
lower in the lower demographics it's not
just high school anymore but you're
seeing kids underneath that get in so
it's gonna have an arc I mean I don't
know where it's gonna go I don't know
what it means
yeah that's fascinating to watch this is
and you know arguably think if as it
happened before like yeah beanie babies
and Cabbage Patch dolls this is a little
different because I think really the the
novelty here is a highly efficient
secondary market that the industry is it
has a membership in providing liquidity
yeah so you've created the marketplace
for creating the primary market and the
secondary market but they currently
don't have their developers building out
the platform for the secondary market
secondary market only pretty much exists
on Craigslist Amazon eBay no stock X Oh
stock exchange stock X stock X yeah
that's the that's the most common place
kids go to stock X okay for exchanging
star putting up and then there's also
the like you said the the addition of a
decentralized digital ledger that can
keep track of all the different products
and them and their and their transits so
to ensure that it's actually one of the
limited edition 20 of them over time I'm
not I haven't seen blockchain play a
role yet so the authentication is a huge
problem
yeah one of the things that stock X
tries to do is they do some degree of
authentication but the fact that there
are knock-offs is it is the own little
culture some people wear knockoffs
knowing that it's not so that the market
figures itself out there's a whole
evolution but there's like that that
stock where people don't even want to
open it it still feels
what does it mean if you were once
that's why I think it's as much about
culture as it as a business and and you
know Suprema is the brand I'm a they've
been around decades the key thing that
I've observed is that the only thing
that really matters at the end day is
brand so if you don't have brand
none of these things can you really be
competitive in and if you have brand you
there's almost no wrong you can do so as
much as people are scrambling to try to
figure out this market the step-back
position is you know somebody like Kanye
I mean somebody's got brand like that
can essentially dictate the terms of how
that Aldus operates I think this is a
good segue into intelligence because
there's almost as though there was no
there was no prediction about this there
was we were very deeply steeped in in
our ignorance about what something would
something like a secondary market like
this could develop and it might have
happened before in the past with all
different kinds of goods but for it to
happen today and for it to be helping
underprivileged areas as well as having
all these complicated math and economics
be crunched so to transition into
intelligence the something that I'd like
to tell you about that I've really been
thinking about a lot lately in it I've
transitioned away from my six rough
drafts that I wrote of Mars race last
year some of Mars Mars race that that
book that I was writing last year to
something that I think's a little bit
more a little bit more grounded in
relatable everyday understandings of
knowledge time in the human race and now
and just one of one of the things about
it that I'd like that I'd like to talk
about in it that I think is a central
thesis for the writing is that there are
only 30,000 days from the moment that
you're born until the moment that you
die it's about 82 years or so and those
days are limited to 24 hours eight hours
for sleep and then the other 16 hours
you can choose to do whatever the hell
you want and in the current economic
fabric we live in
you have to make money and and pay for
your housing and food so in the in in
the book I make it clear that there is a
certain way to if you if you if you view
the this is the first time that I'm
teaching about this I'm glad that's it's
happening to hear your thoughts about it
because this has everything to do with
the point on intelligence that there is
a x axis the x axis is the amount of
time of your life so from zero to thirty
thousand days and then on the y axis is
the knowledge and the knowledge is
absolutely endless and like you like you
say we're ignorant about our ignorance
we don't know what we don't know and so
normally on this x-axis and this y-axis
people typically end up again this is
days thirty thousand this is knowledge
on this is as much as you can know like
whatever van Noy minh and all the guys
that knew whatever so much most people
spend their lives going like this over
time so by the time you die you're
learning about a pretty steady amount
over time or some people go oh educated
and then not that much overtime I'm
trying to hack into that and teach
people how to go like this throughout
their life and that's kind of one of the
central thesis of the writing and and
especially with intelligence being
something that you know that we're gonna
talk about right now do you do you think
that there is a it's very difficult of
course to identify what are these
objective pieces of of knowledge that
can just get you up like that or even
ways for you to understand things like
emotional intelligence and building
rapport with people and being open
minded and caring for people how can
those intelligences ramp you up as well
so do you think that this it's possible
to maybe create some sort of a a these
small little volumes of information for
for people at the age of one at the age
of three at the age of seven at the age
of thirteen for them to learn over time
that could accelerate them like that and
and then hopefully create some sort of a
fabric that people can build
civilization on top of that is agreed
upon Wow I mean we could talk to a
sundown about this because there's so
many offshoots from this you know how
obviously there's no such thing as
intelligence per se it's it encompasses
so many different ideas there's many
different types of intelligence you know
we didn't even talk about like the goal
of intelligence like what is it even a
pursuit onto itself where's in the
service of something else it's easier
talking to much narrower sense and then
leave the rest for other conversations
you know the and you can have
intelligence for its own sake it could
be for as an enjoyment I mean doesn't
have to solve problems per se it doesn't
have to do something it doesn't have to
mean something each other it can just
sit and there's matter intelligence
there's social intelligence committee
intelligence there's interpersonal
intelligence and your infant number of
dimensions
I like prediction markets because it's a
very narrow way to discuss the subject
of how intelligence applied to a
particular marketplace because if you
get forecasts from an economic
perspective it's actually one of the
highest utility function of intelligence
if you can predict the future or be more
right than average you're probably going
to have disproportionate economic
success absolutely and you're probably
gonna get paid for that personally so
that's why I like that as a topic for
today and as it turns out there are many
and that's what this gets you when you
go up in knowledge faster you get more
information which can I'm not sure about
that that's what that's the fun part
because as it turns out there are many
there are many intelligent people in
many markets that underperform
random selection
so in the stock market that's for sure
shoes the stock market the experts are
almost always wrong there compared to if
you just throw a dart so that's
information in there in the one market
where you can actually clear the price
of intelligence as a predictor I'm sorry
intelligence as a tool for production
intelligence underperforms
the average so what does that say about
the rest of the work we're not
accountable we don't have a market
clearing mechanism to determine was that
intelligence actually useful well you
know there's grades and there's tests
and there's other things that that you
can measure but so in other words you
know to be able to you need you need you
know just like in health care we need
Diagnostics Diagnostics are always
imperfect there's no such thing as a
perfect diagnostic regime to measure
study anything everything is an
approximation there there's structural
and system errors and almost everything
measure so as it as it relates to
measuring intelligence you know we are
it's just wide open we don't even know
where to start
and that's why I like sticking the
prediction markets let's ask Cooper
really intelligent people what they
think about this something that has a
lot of different inputs and then let's
run that experiment to see how they do
in these other markets and they're kind
of revisit and what did we mean by
intelligent the first place I also like
ignorance as a subject because I love
things that are uncrowded mmm if you
look at this stay there for a second
loving things that are uncrowded that's
been a key principle of your life and
now key principle of my life loving
things that are uncrowded the black
sheep the when everyone's going right
the what's on the Left what is
interesting over here the 99s going one
way what's on the 1% over here now you
have the Copernicus priority of all
these other great things that are coming
out through you and your family can
continue sure well we're trying to I
personally like the 109 model in terms
of where I spend my time
so this is in the rubric of opportunity
obesity I think on average humans have a
growing number of things that they could
be spending time on the opportunity cost
of everything is inflating so fast we
can't see it because it's intangible so
with rising opportunity costs what do we
do with the overall portfolio of our
time how do we spend it so I never
elected you know five thousand years ago
you would use that time to chisel a
sculpture for twenty years you know in
service so the other ferrule now you
know you can do lots of different things
so I choose to do things that you see
how opportunity obesity bakes into this
model you know like I like looking at
things where most people are leaning one
way and there's a there's an alternative
point of view and most of the time the
majorities on the right track
yeah but sometimes I won't present the
right track so you know I think that's
that's an area that it you know I want
to be able to spend my time now I lost
my trade I thought what was the the
preamble of this so we ignorant ignorant
yep so so so at large I like looking at
a length of Wikipedia entries not even
the detail just looking at it like
30,000 foot view on Wikipedia trees so
to me
ignorance and intelligence are equally
relevant topics but intelligence you've
got a scroll to read it all and
ignorance it literally is like this long
right that's all there is
it's like after that it's like you know
reference Lincoln is yeah so that's a
good way to put it the longer Wikipedia
entries if you look up the word
evolution there's so you have to keep
scrolling down or cowboy okay there's
lots of people looking at it thank God
so I'm grateful this would be so looking
at it I'm looking at things that are
like to me huge topics like oh my god
there's nobody looking at this stuff
yeah doesn't apparently apparently
doesn't pay to look at it where I feel
like it's really valuable just because
there's a pace not valuable so yeah what
do we know about ignorance and there's
and there are people that have studied
in fact it was studied more in the past
and it is now because there's just such
a premium put on
the I've intelligence it almost seems
crass to be talking about the opposite
but it's more difficult to in enroll
your cognition into seeking things that
other people don't know into entering
into ignorance than it is to just sit
back and consume things that we do know
more are creating and other people are
playing it's more visible it's more
tangible and yet it's possible that
ignorant is driving more the outcomes of
what's happening in world and society
and economics of politics and we realize
so if it's such a large variable and
outcomes should we put a little bit more
effort behind understanding in yeah how
do you recommend we and this is very
interesting because we you we did a show
with Alec sent in Boston and you saw the
post and you were like you're impressed
it was a good conversation and Alex is a
person that it goes heavy into trying to
find things that very very few people
are looking at and how do you recommend
and we tried to do the same thing in our
endeavors how do you recommend people
like you said the Wikipedia entries that
all have almost nothing written about
them what other kind of means can people
leverage to find this sort of immunity
an ignorant thing by the way I was
really struck by there are several
things he said that I hadn't heard
before it was it was a interesting way
to organize information so I think he
said something about curiosity where and
I'm actually adding a little bit of my
own interpretation of what he was saying
you know you're being curious if after
you should have forgotten it you still
kind of remember it so in other words
you were being driven by the curiosity
whereas if you're not being driven by
curiosity that information if you can't
retrieve your labor later yeah
curiosity might not have been the true
intention be less poignant whereas when
you're deeply curious but that just
stays with you so that's one way to be
not too honest with yourself what was
driving me yeah so I thought that was a
that is a really good on so you'll
retain information more depending on
your level of curiosity and seeking it
find it so and also the novel novelty in
that information the more unique that
information is the more you'll remember
it because you are also trying to figure
out how to communicate it to other
people
as you encounter something new versus
encountering information that is older
but I'll even then again it's a sense of
curiosity that retains the information
right so the next place to go with that
is because you know we are we're driven
by our subjective experience and we're
very ego driven so everything is a
first-person experience in the same way
that there's there's a lot in the in the
world right now about storytelling it's
all about storytelling right in some
people's eyes we don't think enough
about story listening the so there's
always coevolution between storytelling
and story listening we obviously have
the story listening gene because when
you go to Ted and instead of I've never
been to Ted but if you were to watch Ted
let's take a step back instead of
watching the speaker watch the audience
yes why are 500 people sitting there so
we clearly have a story listening gene I
mean there's there's a reason why
there's people on the other side of this
camera what is the say about us and
there's always been this coevolution
that predates anything we know about
human evolution that we've even before
humans there's been this coevolution of
story telling the story listening so
same thing with curiosity if you think
curiosity is a trait then you
immediately should think about the
desire for being curious the pond
there's always there's probably been
this coalition going on so think about
it from the perspective of a person so
one thought that connects your mind is
does this person obviously wants to be
kurios upon yeah to be your first date
so you think about that's also when you
see a laptop open during a talk or the
right exactly it's a boa
demand for curio well I'm sorry not
curious about you but they want you to
be curious about them so when you think
about how nature presents itself
think about a flower versus
stem the flower is saying to you I want
you to be curious about me the stem is
saying to you you can ignore me a person
you know on a date it could be safety I
want you to be curious about this aspect
of me so if you're paying attention you
can you can have this second person
experience about curiosity instead of
the first person because again the the
classic thing in psychology is we think
about ourselves first our own experience
of that word so when people think about
curiosity the thing about my curiosity
not your curiosity and this is one of
the things that I've been practicing
with active listening and emotional
intelligence is whenever you first meet
somebody it's so it's so important to be
very you know friendly and genuine and
loving and then when you ask them a
really good question right away aim to
ask them a good question
ask them what they care about or what
they're passionate about or what they're
building into the world and when you ask
them that you're your first of all
you're not focusing on yourself at all
you're focusing on them and then second
of all is when you take that that
perspective of analysis like you said
the second person perspective analysis
what you're doing is you're you're
observing what they're saying and
finding the keys of what they're saying
oh I care about education Oh what do you
care about educate you care about it
what are you building with education and
then you're asking them more and more
questions to get deeper and deeper into
their values and their principles what
to care about this is how you can find
people around you really quickly that
have similar values or different values
than you do and why they care about
certain things that ability is that
ability is probably one of the most
underdeveloped now abilities story
listening I love that as a co-evolved
trait with storytelling so when you look
at the flow of what's going on in
simulation the audience is watching
because they're curious you're asking
questions you're curious and you're
asking questions about people who
themselves are manifest
the curiosity throughout the world so
curiosity is a closer approximation to
the truth than intelligence intelligence
kind of mapping phenomenon but the the
tighter flow of what's going on it
curious is much closer to whatever the
center of all this is mmm-hmm okay so
even though okay so even though you're
you're climbing up with with with
intelligence and we talked about this
actually on another show is that the it
really and this is what you were
mentioning with Alex as well is it the
retention of the information will come
from being curious when you're fed back
into your mouth you're like okay but
when you're curious and you're feeding
yourself you're remembering and you're
and you're scaling up up faster I like
how you said that curiosity's closer to
the source of like what's going on with
truth than intelligences that's a good
one well we have yet to maybe unpack
that one more ok let's do a couple other
things before we and I think there's so
much more to talk about okay how about
the why why hip hop why hypocrisy why
why is this something that we need a
that we need to talk about yeah it'd be
nice to give the community tools to
understand it better and we are it was
actually one of the first words I taught
my kids just because it was a fun word
and then in the process of teaching well
I realized I was being a hypocrite about
soda because I yeah you know my son you
ask me use the hypocrisy in a sentence
hypocrite in a sentence if dad my father
my dad is a hypocrite because he drinks
Diet Coke he won't let me have any like
oh my god I had no idea yeah so and I
immediately quit then I switched the
coffee instead so hypocrisy is a first
pot that we should see it as a trait not
it's and it's probably a feature not a
bug
although it can be very buggy so
hypocrisy where is where there's a delta
between either actions or a belief
systems and what we actually do and
there's probably this gamesmanship
between individual interests and group
interests that we have to constantly
toggle back and forth between so there's
a lot more virtual signaling about or
what we aspire to verses or actions so
we on average we probably tend to fall
short but it gives us room to improve it
gives us a goal so there's probably a
hypocrisy has always been around the the
part that interests me is there's
obviously a sort of this dark hypocrisy
whereas intentional and nefarious and
there's a sort of unintentional
hypocrisy that's in some cases even
comical this blissful ignorance about
our hypocrisy and then there's this gray
area where I can't tell if it's
duplicitous or if it's just blissful
ignorance and that's where a lot of the
energy comes from so to help clean this
up
I wish the English language had better
taxonomy for Apocrypha the ones that are
clearly intentioned driven for whatever
reasons and maybe it's even positive
today I don't know versus blissful
ignorance there's that ignorance word
again and then the third category yeah
we're on the gray and let's make some
neologisms let's do it yeah what's
holding us back and we want the
community the community can make you
think that exactly let's make it let's
make it together then once we can in it
because if you call something a
hypocrite now it's so negative that you
choose not to call it hypocrite so then
all this wolf oh you just persist
because we don't have the words for we
know other tools so we don't have the
ability to identify that in ourselves
let alone each other
hypocrite almost always is associated
with nefarious a negative exactly so
then the rest of this you know in the
whole gradient of disconnected views and
the Delta between our actions and our
words
we have no way to really evolve around
that because immediately you have an
allergic reaction to the word and
sometimes cadence and flexion things
like that can actually help a lot this
is that those emotional intelligence
skills that we were mentioning earlier
June you're kind of being a hypocrite
right now by saying that your that's so
much more playful and kind but but then
is that person actually registering that
oh yeah I am being hypocritical about
that thing so then there's all that okay
that's a good point
massive room for improvement because if
you could take all the blissful
ignorance in the gray area and help
people reach their aspirational goals if
they want to because some people may
actually prefer the Delta to hold the
Delta then I think you know just just
when you think about total value in the
system
just this debts based loss if you can
just narrow that you're already create a
huge value without any innovation like
we're there anything new no new
information no new technology it's just
being able to move up the chain what we
intend to do it did we actually do what
we intended to do if we actually live up
to our own goals or own aspirations
that'd be a quick way to expand a lot of
value this is something that we talk
about a lot which is conscientiousness
self authoring the this notion of
setting goals for yourself and being
very critical with the analysis of how
you are achieving your short-term and
long-term goals and trying to you know
author your future through this sort of
a manifestation of values and principles
that you have within you out into the
world through your creations that brings
so much meaning fulfillment to life and
if were and this is something that I
would really like to hear your thoughts
on about as we kind of wrap up is what
are your thoughts about making a better
social fabric for self and collective
actualization well I think it would
start with
moving beyond moslems hierarchy so it's
almost been a regression to Freud and
Maslow from previous states so I'm going
to throw up our 15 minutes I'm not sure
sure so 42 okay perfect thank you give
us the noise though cuz that likely our
show cuz I like the noise yeah random
constraint well this all starts with
school so we actually go to school you
think in one hour blocks here cuz the
noise oh that's cool that's our that's
our 15 minute time which is when we flip
that it's not necessarily an hour long
show but we do like to we're open to
have two hour-long conversations but we
want to be very kind to people so when
they see the video they're like oh it's
only 54 instead of oh it's an hour and
60 minutes that's an action digit yeah
so uncrowded trades I do that three-hour
massage so it's not until you get to the
third hour they actually start to have
the experience their first hour it's
just it's small talk with the hands
right you just still getting past the
greetings and the second hour the most
college is when you actually start to
relax at third ours is like
transcendence so that's what I love
camping trips because it's it's a way to
break the routine of small talk because
you're living in small talk in nine
amperes on your time yeah and the
camping trip you get past a small talk
and then and then you start to have a
conversation so it's a nice forcing
function so social fabric
self-actualization
so the potential the human potential
graphic you're welcome just heads okay
you got eyes all over the human
potential is when we start focusing on
the actualization of others so once you
get out of the first person experience
Freud was a symptom of the alienation
that been going on for centuries as we
became disconnected and then these weird
feelings plus industrialization and plus
all the leisure time allowed him to
start start with
you know the first person hit in the ego
and then we went to mid-century and then
Maslow defined all that the highest
state of highest need is
self-actualization as it turned out from
since peaking at time it was always
about the nurturing of the actualization
of others it's only when we face the
alienation that we start to focus on
ourselves so we're gonna event you to
the return trip so the social fabric
comes from the ability the willingness
to nurture the acquisition of others so
if we can think about that agency rather
than focusing on one zone socialization
like how do I help actualize and
activate others will be the return of
the sociopathic we always have so this
isn't inventing something new this is
just return to the past it's gonna take
us a long time to kind of reinvent that
because this journey is you know it's
like any hero's journey just taking some
time and we're on our way home know
slowly I think the notion of you know
picking yourself up and cleaning up your
own room and going forth into the world
and making something of value is but
taking responsibility on your back
that's also important so is the
collective working together to help
underprivileged areas to become
information highways so to have closer
access to computers and technology to
give them the ability to learn things
like sketch and programming and scratch
and all these different ways to help
their actualization so I think it's such
a multivariate discussion that is
usually just made into a into a hey do
you know go do it go do it yourself or
people that are too focused on receiving
help and help and help aren't picking
themselves up enough so well there's a
person that's receiving in this person
that's giving it but if there's a
mutuality so the idea isn't to I mean
the reason self-reliance was written in
the 1800's it was it again I was a
phenomenon so there was a this
dependency there's atrophy this lack of
volition that was happening so it was a
great thing there right because there
that's a dependency that can be
undermining right but that's not what
we're talking about here where I think
we're talking about mutuality if people
are supporting each other in addition to
supporting themselves so it's not like
this isn't about being Mother Teresa
it's about you know some of its to
manifest your destiny some of us to
support others there's always been this
balance and when the balance tips one
way or another then people start writing
books about culture so the need for
social fabric today is you know we're
we've definitely been in a anymore
journey and disproportionate focus on
one's own well-being
not only the ignorance of other for
sometimes at the cost of others and then
there's alienation and that's what kind
of people are vaguely feeling out there
which if I Bernie man is such a mudstone
tearjerker for people because once this
becomes a norm can we talk about this
this is the I really think you know I
love people that are optimistic there's
a there's a really small group of people
that I think truly have faith in people
like relentless faith in people
mm it's really wonderful being around
Larry Harvey was one of those people and
to me Burning Man is an expression of
his faith in people who has faith in
people anymore it's awesome well turns
out a few people do enough people do and
Burning Man is an expression of that but
like many people I was resistant to go
in the brain yet so it's my 19th year
and you know and I I am a crazy optimist
in the sense that I think we will solve
everything and couldn't go into Mars and
longevity but I mean that metaphor does
it mean to solve everything I don't know
but let's just say we solve everything
unless I tend to agree with you
yeah that's like five thousand years and
then we talked about this simulation
last time you know I think we're gonna
return to this we're it's gonna be the
fire we know how to fire today mm-hmm
but we've sitting around the fire
telling stories singing dancing which
was what we were doing until 5,000 years
ago so this is the 10,000 year grand
interlude it's the only abnormal period
of human history and Burning Man has
that glimpse so Burning Man
is a rare glimpse into the timeless
beyond their what was ever more what
will be evermore and what was until now
and when you embark on that journey is
when you start seeing so I didn't
realize I couldn't see until I got to
the gate at Burning Man
after years of resisting so and you know
it's the craziest entry because you you
this person says welcome home and I'm
like what a strange thing to say to
somebody just met and this is nothing
like my home because I just I know I
left home I know what it looks like
there's food shelter water this is the
opposite yeah
of what I think about home and you know
hours from home it's very uncomfortable
so I'm like most normal people I resist
it because all the stories that my
friends told me made me not want to go
and all the photos because if you look
at the photos it it looks like Pompeii
and everything is covered
yeah and dust yeah like it looks like
you just photograph on page it looks
except it's not actually Pompeii it's
probably in the outskirts of Pompeii at
a trailer park because it's all these
RVs that are covered in dust so like why
would I want to go and all the photos of
people it looks like they were frozen
you know their expressions their poses
it's what you'd expect that of people
that basically didn't have enough time
to put their clothes on before the
volcano erupted that's what the photos
looked like so I said no I don't I don't
want to go to this thing it doesn't make
sense not for me you know this is the
mind games in our minds play and then
finally one of my college friends
they've been going for years and they
you know we aren't expecting someone at
4 by the way so but it's but it's ok you
can just we can just let them know to to
hang out for if you need to let them
yeah yeah of course sure yeah
it's Martina in bed by the way yep here
we go back at it yes continue you're
going on Burning Man very beautiful way
very beautiful way so ok I'm just
remembering my first time and welcome my
yeah and my college friend said well
forget all the stories and pictures do
you trust us like I trust you uh you can
only trust people so much I love them
dearly but you know what when she start
calling yourself a Bern remind why is
that that feels like a cult right anyway
but so I but I do trust them so I just
had to go and I trusted him enough to go
but not enough to not drive separately I
drove separately with my own getaway car
because I wasn't sure what need how many
days he could take now wasn't sure I
wasn't sure and because it goes 10 days
we can go as long as you want it to and
you can go 3 days or 10 days yes I think
the event is like a nine days okay this
is my first time I think it was a
Wednesday anyway so this person is
knocking on my window and I'm like I'm
not gonna roll down the window I'm in
the middle of a dust hurricane hey guys
and this person so that's the second
reason that it was so weird to be told
welcome home because this is not the
person I would be expecting to greet me
at home this person was wearing ski
goggles and it had been flat and hot for
hours we're nowhere near a ski resort
we're in the middle of the desert you
know and I don't know what to think
I mean again I I don't know if I've been
had this whole Burning Man thing
there hasn't been a lot of media
coverage at this point and and you know
and she was as I say she wasn't wearing
much except a smile except I couldn't
tell she was smiling because she had
this bandana on mm-hmm
she looked like a bandit so I mean I
wasn't sure if I was about to get a I
was about to get carjacked that's what
it looked like
we're in the middle of the desert she's
totally like incognito
she says open your trunk and I don't
know what that meant I they're like huh
so I actually it's very hard to pack for
Burning Man it's much easier oh yeah I
pack as if I was going to be fleeing the
country because you don't know when
you're going to the Burning Man I had to
pack everything in fact I think I think
fleeing to Mexico I'd pack a lot last I
just bring a Visa card here I had to
bring everything cuz visa the money
doesn't work why is she interested in
the trunk I know cuz I have no idea
turns out there are stowaways and
there's reasons why they want to look
under the hood and look in the trunk and
it was really one person clinging to the
chasis of the vehicle so there's amazing
there's amazing stories about and that's
how desperate people are to get in the
stowaways I mean that like caught my
attention - people are like doing
everything they can to go home to this
place yeah and once you get inside it
all starts to make sense because the the
when you're there because then you're
then you're seeing the timeless hmm
and I mean and people are literally some
of them are reduced to tears yeah
because then you realize everything he
also is abnormal yeah and this was the
only normal thing unless you hadn't seen
it so that the the closest experience I
could describe would be somebody on the
way to Mars or somewhere really far away
they were born on the plane and you hear
stories about earth and you're going
this journey and then one day you return
home to earth and to see earth that's
probably you know an approximation of
what it feels like to see Bernie because
now you actually see you know the
timeless and I think that's why people
are so moving and that's why it feels
like you're home so the best way to
describe Burning Man is that you are
going home to a place
you've never been before he's all be
like somebody who colonized Mars going
back to her and that's what Larry
created so you know when he when he
passed recently you know it was a
enormous loss right obviously for his
family and his friends but I think for
the Kamiel arge
there are so few people that really had
their finger on the pulse of what's
going on yeah I mean look like the world
has all the people like that - yeah so
this year's Burning Man I think will be
especially special yes because it would
be a celebration of Larry yeah I'm sorry
that you didn't get to have him on the
show the beauty of what the mind can do
for bringing people together out in the
middle apparently the first ones were on
Baker beach that's so interesting we
were just learning about that from Eddie
Cadell who had been to Burning Man 13
times there's something he was telling
us about it that that people coming
together in a state of timelessness is
so amazing to do in today's busy world
and to do it in a place like you said
where it's ski goggles and and these
anchor shifts preventing you from
inhaling all the dust and it's coming up
it's definitely something that you
recommend to go and experience I highly
recommend it so if you could think about
Burning Man as a manifestation of
somebody who had faith in people going
there your faith will grow because you
realize this is a blank canvas and all
the beautiful things you're seeing is an
expression of a human being and then
whatever cynicism one might have starts
to take a backseat and you start to
appreciate people and it's that faith in
people that makes the makes the dominoes
keep falling throughout history around
that no we got other guests we do so
everyone let's keep some faith in people
let's do it let's build a future
together June we covered so many great
topics this show that was a good show
awesome no sir grab me your your first
show in the studio we have done
a couple other shows prior to this
everything from the National Institute
of nutrition to hypebeast
culture to intelligence and to Burning
Man and hypocrisy so interesting
covering all these topics everyone thank
you for tuning in find more information
on june yoon in the bio dr. joon-young
calm and all of his different projects
help collaborate with him join us in the
movement the simulation movement let's
inspire people to build the future
across all these different topics join
us by subscribing
either gently press the bun maybe smash
the button join the family join us give
a comment below with your thoughts on
the episode will feature you on our
Twitter on our Instagram give us a
comment below let us know your thoughts
like the post as well share it get
talking about it and get inspired to
build something from it
join us on patreon so crucial we got to
sustain the studio space we got to grow
we got to impact more people so join us
there
Ron Vargas are producing partner thank
you so much Joon Yoon such a sound thank
you this is gonna blast more soon peace
[Music]